[Music]
post-credit scenes are a staple of
modern day comic book movies it's rare
that we get a film without one and it
appears that venom will be no different
after a recent interview with Fandango
director Ruben Fleischer stated that it
would be a mistake to not stay through
the credits of a superhero movie and
asked about if venom would have one
this pretty much confirms that there
will be one present in the upcoming Tom
Hardy flick and several theories are
abound on the internet as to what could
appear many are hoping for an appearance
by Tom Holland whilst others are sure
that carnage will be the one making a
cameo personally I'm leaning more
towards the latter as I highly doubt
that the MCU would allow the character
to appear as it would immediately take
away from the cliffhanger death of the
character at the end of infinity war
Sony are clearly trying to build a
cinematic universe that doesn't rely on
marble so I think the after credit scene
will feature carnage those who are fans
of spider-man will be aware of the
rivalry between the villains and it
makes the most sense logically sources
close to the film have leaked that this
is the case however these are
unconfirmed reports so can only be
viewed as speculative for the time being
so are you looking forward to venom
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoyed this video then please like it
and subscribe to my channel I create
content like this weekly and they'll
definitely be something on here that you
love if you're a fan of film make sure
you check out my video discussing why I
think venom will work linked at the end
of this one and thanks again for taking
the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
you
[Music]